hey guys my name is Jess McDonald today
is the 31st of March and you're watching
gamespot news i remind you that tomorrow
is april fools day sir trust nothing and
nobody up there are some sweet looking
special edition consoles in the world
and certainly have just added another
one if you're a big fan of the Batman
you may be keen on Sony's new four
hundred and fifty dollar limited edition
bundle it contains a copy of batman
arkham knight a steel gray ps4 featuring
an arkham knight faceplate and a
matching dualshock 4 controller if you'd
prefer to go for the original black ps4
console plus controller sony will not
fifty dollars off the bundles price tag
sony have also announced that Arkham
Knight bonus content including
additional missions and custom skins for
Batman and his transport of choice the
Batmobile will be available first on ps4
you can digitally pre-order the game and
the hardware bundles from now next up by
employing pure skill and just a few
exploits one blood-borne player has
completed the game in just over 40
minutes youtube user ergonomic EV has
posted the video up on his page and
claims the run now stands as a world
record he was aiming to speedrun the
game with any percentage of completion
and with the use of exploits including
the items you plication cheat while
using glitches is a controversial way to
go about it finding and executing those
exploits is a trial in and of itself so
this is still an impressive feat agha no
told Eurogamer that while he's pleased
with the run he's certain that he can
get faster finally the debut trailer for
Star Wars Battlefront is just weeks away
EA have confirmed that the game's debut
trailer will be coming on April 17 at
1030am Pacific the publisher had
confirmed earlier that we would be
hearing about the game at the star wars
celebration event which takes place in
April so far all we've seen from the
game is a teaser trailer from last
year's e3 but EA are promising that
alongside the upcoming trailer attendees
of the Star Wars event will get the
chance
see battlefront game play behind closed
doors during the show at their official
boot let me know down in the comments if
you're more excited to star wars
battlefront or batman arkham knight and
why you can add to gain salt or we've
got news on april's free playstation
crafts games and the upcoming info from
Nintendo Direct those are all the things
that I wanted to tell you about today as
always do leave me your thoughts and
feelings and i'll catch you same time
tomorrow